it's so lovely to meet you both I love
this movie and thought you were both so
so wonderful in it something I think
that's so brilliant about this movie is
the way that it really portrays this
very complex cycle of abuse and explores
these very nuanced sort of power
dynamics so I was wondering how did you
think about your character's place in
that cycle and where they sort of fit in
that power dynamic as the Elders of the
group well I think as the elders we were
um both Greta and Agatha were
I think may I say slightly more
concerned about our children and our
grandchildren who experience the abuse
and so in in coddling them and taking
care of them and making sure you know
showing great empathy to them it helped
us certainly I felt that way about Greta
yeah yeah I I
um in many ways I could never quite
reconcile whether Agatha went through
the the actual abuse physically that
everyone else did but it didn't matter
because it had happened to my daughters
and to my grandchild and of course the
other women in the community who were my
are my friends and and other relatives
I'm sure so it might as well have
happened to me yeah definitely and that
sort of leads to my next question for
you Sheila I want to talk about that
moment where your character apologizes
to her daughter because it's such a
powerful moment I know it was a little
bit different in the script too so I'm
curious sort of how you approach that
scene and what it sort of means to you
well you know under the tutelage of
Sarah Paulie you know she's just an
incredible director and gives you
permission and creates such a safety net
for those very difficult scenes also
working with Jesse Buckley
um was amazing I you know I was a dancer
my whole life and I like to do things
always the same way and Jessie's the
exact opposite so not that we were
improvising but we we um that scene was
very fluid and it changed and and I I
you know not to make too light of it you
know I'm a Canadian and we apologize a
lot so I'm just saying sorry more than
once was just part in my DN in My DNA
but you know I I it was just one of
those moments that I don't I don't like
like I can hardly touch on because I
don't quite remember where we were all
at during that it was just one of those
magical moments of indefinable
filmmaking I guess yeah definitely as
someone from the Midwest I understand
the apology thing so definitely
once isn't enough it's not no you have
to keep going yeah Judith I know that
you mentioned that this rule sort of
reminded you of your grandmother and it
felt like doing an homage to her can you
talk a little bit about that and how you
prepared and how it did kind of feel
like stepping into her shoes in a way
well my grandmother was very religious
and I say in a very happy way
um and she was she had so many of the
qualities that that seemed to be agathas
at the when I first read the script and
read the the book then after that of not
judging people wanting to listen to
people wanting to hear how they felt uh
she had a great laugh and she enjoyed
um uh jokes and funny stories and that
was in the script that as far as I was
concerned that that Agatha was going to
have fun with as much as she possibly
could and and try to inspire others so
that that to me is it really keyed me in
on on Grandma
I love that Sheila did you have any
influences that you took to play your
character as well uh you know not not
the pieces of people I suppose I I
really enjoyed Greta's um quiet humor
and it's something that Sarah and I
talked a lot about initially and we're
just trying to find a little
um pieces of sort of rhiness to diffuse
uh the tense situations you know in an
argumental you know argument kind of
situation where where Greta could say
you know I want to talk about Ruth and
Cheryl my horses again just to dispel
what was going on so I really loved that
I
thought that that was
um kind of necessary that it couldn't
all be you know
sad yeah I think the comedy makes you
know the darker stuff even more
impactful in a way
um so the younger members have spoken a
lot about what they sort of learned from
the veterans on the set I'm curious if
there's anything you feel like you took
from watching them oh
Where Do We Begin I mean there's nothing
in their way they just were so open and
we were not at all I mean
it's harder for us now I think in a
weird way well
it's we grew up in a time where this
abuse of power and how you behave as men
and women together was different and
they there as it says at the end of the
movie their world is different and so
their approach to so many subjects just
when we when the actors were sitting
around talking
um it that's what I learned from it's a
it awakened in Mia uh a bigger question
about how I uh felt about my
relationship with other women
yeah definitely
um and all the characters I think have
such depth and really get their moments
to shine if you could play a different
character in the film who would you want
to sort of dig into and explain what a
good question to ask you wow well if I
were to play Who I Really Am I'd be
Salon I I
yeah I would jump right in with all
those axes and and spray cans and
everything that would be my gut reaction
to this to the situation so I would I
think I would jump to um Ben wishaw's
character August
I maybe it's similar to gretison but I
loved I loved his part
yeah his yeah yeah he has such an
interesting sort of layer to it all
um and he fits in so interestingly with
this sort of community of all of the
women I'm curious how you sort of found
and fostered that dynamic between you
all because it is so powerful and feels
so authentic between everyone well you
know we were we had the luxury of
rehearsing for two weeks which you know
you don't usually get in filmmaking also
offset we were all in one big communal
room like the hay loft with our covid
partitions so we were all together a lot
and the poor you know crew getting the
women to stop talking so that we could
make a movie called women talking was
quite a challenge so um we you know
there was a lot of Joy on set yeah that
helped us get through it all covid was
actually a help to us in many ways
because there were so many you know
rules and regulations in order to keep
everybody healthy and it lent itself
keeping us as a group so we would finish
a scene upstairs in The Hayloft and come
back down to this conference room where
they had put us with our tables and our
chairs and our sleeping mats and
everything and uh and just start right
in talking about our lives as Judy and
Sheila yeah
we found out one day probably we've
worked with 150 people in common yeah
just saying do you know so-and-so oh
yeah I know that yeah War Stories the
best
that's incredible well thank you both so
much um thank you for getting a chance
to talk to you and I can't wait for
everyone to see the movie thank you